هناك عشرات المنافسين الذين يقدمون محتوى
لكن وهذا الشيء صراحه دائما يدعونا الى
المفخره العربيه يوجد بينها وبين اقرب
منافس مسافات صراحه خصوصا خلال السنوات
الثلاث الماضيه لانه استراتيجيه العربيه
قامت على انه احنا نوسع الانتشار ونقوي
المحتوى الموجود على منصات التواصل يعني
مثلا في عام 2022 حسب هذا الموقع الذي
اشرت اليه لابس العربيه كانت اكثر صانع
محتوى اخباري على مستوى العالم يحظى بعدد
مشاهدات سنويه احنا كنا نتحدث حينها عن 14
مليار مشاهده حققتها منصات التواصل في
اكثر من مره تم تصنيف مواقع العربيه على
انها الاكثر متابعه ولاكثر مشاهده على
سبيل المثال العربيه كانت اول محطه توصل
عشره ملايين متابع على منصه يوتيوب حاليا
هي بين صانعي الاخبار هي الاولى من حيث
عدد المتابعين نتحدث عن 12 مليون متابع
على فيسبوك كذلك الحال العربيه لديها اكثر
من 30 مليون متابع ايضا على تيك توك
وبالمناسبه المنصه حديثه على صانعي
المحتوى العربيه هي الاولى الان لدينا
حوالي
مليونير متابع ولدينا مشاهدات مليونيه
العربيه منتشره بك والحدث طبعا الشبكه
كلها منتشره بكثافه من خلال المنصات
العديده ومن خلال المحتوى المتنوع والشامل
والاخباري الذي يقدم الى الجمهور